hey you guys time once again for a movie
retrospective going only back to the 90s
this time only was such a long time ago
when this one came out 1997 this game L
this is event horizon that's very
interesting because the very same day or
actually I think it was the next day
that someone in the YouTube comments
requested this movie I had just noticed
that Netflix had either just added it or
it was just in the trending because I
hadn't seen it before
so I was like well [ __ ] I guess we'll do
that one yeah maybe somebody had Netflix
maybe said hey this was one that I think
I saw when it came out and then I kind
of like forgot about it because this is
another one of those ones that came out
and it did really really badly like at
the box office and like you know critics
were kind of like but then like later
later on it kind of you know got a big
cult following so it was another kind of
one of those this was actually direct
I'm not sure if you know this but this
was directed by Paul WS Anderson who
also did soldier okay and he did the
he's probably best known for doing the
Mortal Kombat movie the first one which
was really successful he did alien vs.
predator he's done like a bunch of the
Resident Evil movies I was thinking at
the time some of the shouts of some of
the sets it looks like yeah it was like
that looks like some house soldier well
yeah see you called it yeah yeah because
it's the same director it's a different
kind of story but I guess it's in the
same universe I guess it might yeah
although I'm gonna say soldiers in
Ridley Scott's future and really Scott's
personnel yeah and that's basically what
they said the thing about this one is
that I think how it started out like the
script that was first going around was
actually more like alien you know what I
mean whereas you know what attack to the
ship was like tentacle aliens yeah so I
guess when Paul WS Anderson got hold of
the screenplay because he had actually
like I said he did the first Mortal
Kombat which was like a huge success and
he got offered the sequel to that which
was Mortal Kombat annihilation and he
said man I really want to direct that
he's like he was sick of doing pg-13
movies yeah so he wanted to do rated R
movie so he liked this script but he's
like well it's too much like alien he's
like I want to make it more like
a classic haunted house story like The
Shining or the haunting or some like
that only in space
yeah that's wheeze God basically yes is
a haunted ship it's a lot actually in a
way it kind of reminded me a lot of the
black Disney's the black hole it is kind
of similar to that in the sense yeah an
expedition to find a [ __ ] abandoned
ghost ship basically and that's that's
how the movie starts is that premise and
in the sense that you're also getting
kind of like a sci-fi slash gothic cross
over a little bit because this really
does look like you got you know your
sci-fi element but you also have your
sort of possession element yeah and for
you youngsters they haven't seen the
black hole go see the black hole yeah we
did a review they did a review of it
it's Disney's only science fiction film
it was kind of like a gothic horror yeah
kind of is - except this one is more
like it's funny to me that some people
say that you know yeah it is similar to
alien it is similar to you know the
shining and things like that but to me
it's more similar to Hellraiser yeah I
guess because of all the gore and like
the sadomasochistic sort of gore also
very similar in premise to solaris the
russian movie which came out in the 70s
and they actually did I think did like
an english-language remake of that
wasn't killing and Murphy in that I want
to say her song I remember it being good
but um it's it's essentially the same
premise whereas you know here's this
experimental ship with a gravity drive
on it called the event horizon and it
went missing and seven years later it
turns up again like in an orbit around
Neptune
so this crew that are kind of like the
alien crew like kind of working-class
joe's so they have to go out there on
the ship called the Lewis and Clark and
they have to go check it out and see if
there's anybody else like you know alive
on it or anything yes same premise is
the black hole yeah and they're taking
with them the guy that invented the
gravity Drive who's played by Sam Neill
who's playing doctor weir and who may or
may not be kind of crazy even from the
beginning
maybe yeah I don't think that because
here's the most people have seen event
horizon I think that early snow with the
premises I mean basically the ship has
gone into a black hole because that's
what it was supposed to do it was
supposed to like the gravity Drive was
supposed to like make black holes and
then it you know sucked it is sucks it
under gravity goes like you you know do
a warp like in war hammer comes
singularity in it yeah punch a hole
through the dimensions yeah so they can
get some work quiz it was actually
explained to go he explains it it
doesn't the science doesn't really hold
up but doesn't matter just move well and
nowadays you wouldn't really have to
explain it because I think most people
that would be watching a sci-fi movie so
it's a wormhole and everybody gave in it
but you know back in the 90s I guess
they thought that maybe so he had to do
the thing where he took like the budget
pencil through that yep there goes that
yeah yeah well you know like I said
maybe like traveling but not moving and
then space goes back like that yeah
thing is everything's Jake like in dune
yeah so yeah so that's the thing we're
so it was supposed to be the the event
horizon was actually supposed to be
making a black hole and going through a
wormhole and going to Proxima Centauri
however it went into some dimension and
they're not entirely sure what it was
however as the movie goes on you find
out it is essentially a Hell dimension
kind of yeah or the Clive Barker to make
sure they shake all it makes you feared
fears and everything come true yeah and
also a almost kind of like Forbidden
Planet yeah like that kind of town yeah
where they found that alien machine that
made your it gave you're in a way of
making itself manifest that usually as a
big as monster yeah because I feel like
- he also kind of had a thing where the
ship itself became like a sentient being
yeah you know what I mean
yeah it wasn't buying that part but
that's what they were making it that's
what they're trying to make itself yeah
well like I said I think that's where
comparisons to like The Shining and the
haunting and stuff like that because
like I said I got way more of like a
Hellraiser a Solaris vibe but I think
that when he said he wanted to make the
shining in space or the haunting in
space I think he was talking more about
the about making the ship an entity like
a living entity much like the Overlook
Hotel
or the house and you know in the
haunting yeah and I must admit it it
doesn't really work it didn't work for
me well the thing about this though it's
like it's weird because so this came out
what ended up happening with this movie
was one it was super rushed because what
ends up happening is that the so they
give you know anderson like sixty
million dollars to make this however
they said well we have Titanic coming
out later this year so we want like a
hit movie like before Titanic comes out
so we can have like however many hits in
a year or whatever so they gave them
money but they said you only have you
know X amount of time and it was like
some not enough amount of time the
problem arose when normally I guess
according to like the Directors Guild or
whatever you're supposed to have a
minimum of ten weeks for the editing
process but because the studio had
already you know slated a release date
for event horizon he ended up only
having six weeks but in practice he
really only ended up having four weeks
because he was still doing second unit
stuff like in those Linda's first two
weeks that he was supposed to be editing
it so what ended up happening was that
the first cut of this movie was two
hours and ten minutes long and they
showed it to test audiences and test
audiences didn't like it mostly because
it was way too gory and the studio
didn't like it either because they
didn't expect it they thought it was
just gonna be like a sci-fi monster
movie I guess and it's like they didn't
they didn't expect all the evisceration
like all the gouges and stuff that
happens in this movie so you know there
was a lot of negative feedback so
Paramount comes out and was like well
can you take about thirty minutes
out of it mostly the gore but some of
the other stuff was cut as well so they
ended up like taking a bunch of stuff
out so what have been better with the
gory I think so and Paul and Paul
Anderson thought that as well so he was
like very very disappointed but he was
like on a very very tight schedule you
know he not all the scenes that were cut
work or some of it was like additional
character development you know
additional scenes like you know kind of
establishing the hell premise but a lot
of that was taken out so what ended up
happening though so the movie comes out
like in the theaters it cost sixty
million dollars to make and it only made
like twenty six and a half million back
yeah so it was a big failure yeah but
the weird thing about it is that however
like a year or two later when it was
released on DVD it was like a massive
hit like suddenly yeah well we know it
was like back then yeah I mean this is
still this is 90s this is yeah seven oh
yeah I know exactly what it was like
back then yeah he had blockbuster true
you had all those damn video rental
stores yeah and kids were when I was a
kid growing up it was it was a lot more
likely that you were gonna be able to go
down to Blockbuster and rent some [ __ ]
for you and your buddies you know over
yeah Friday or Saturday night that's
kind of whatever you did yeah that was
that's what you did and so it was more
convenient than going to the theater
yeah you know and and it was more it was
cheaper trail it was cheaper and a movie
that you would rent and loved you
probably wouldn't like to have paid the
damn full price to go through see it to
the theater and I think that kind of
still applies nowadays like people will
watch stuff on Netflix and be like oh
it's no good but it's like they wouldn't
necessarily have risked like spending 12
13 14 they had they but had they spent
$12 on it they would have said well
wasn't that good right yeah no yeah
because we came from you know we came
from an era where we'd watch the same
movie [ __ ] five six times eight times
because they weren't play it over and
over on HBO and Cinemax
so some movies just kind of got burned
into you like the old Flash Gordon I
[ __ ] love that I didn't realize how
good it looked until I got it on blu-ray
and on a modern TV and I saw that one in
the theater too but I yeah
when you're you and your kid you know I
mean you're not you're not really paying
attention why is it not as cool as it
was when the theater was HD basically
you know and your TV were fuzzy yeah but
it was just you know yeah this is
something that would do real well at
block yeah because it seems like
something that people would be like oh
this looks cool and and I think word of
mouth got around about two especially
among horror fans that it was like
pretty gory and it had some disturbing
imagery so a lot of people like picked
up on it so as soon as it came out on
DVD and it was like a big huge success
paramount goes back to Paul WS Anderson
and says hey let's do a director's cut
because we know you were mad about
having to take all of that footage out
Retton it doesn't matter if it's in the
theater or not yeah so it's like but
what ended up happening was in the
interim however long it was before the
theatrical release because it's it's it
used to be longer than it is now because
now it just seems like a couple months
later like it's out on streaming or
whatever but back then it was usually
like a year or two yeah so in the
interim all of the footage that had been
cut out had been lost as it been like
misfiled or it was destroyed or
something like that like somebody just
misplaced it or it wasn't stored
properly or whatever so the only thing
that still exists of his original cut
the one that they showed the test
audiences is like a VHS tape so because
somebody found it like a friend of his
that was like at Paramount or whatever's
like hey I found this is your rough cut
right but it's on VHS so it's all video
quality yeah now they do know like I I
know that there have been there were a
couple scenes that and maybe they're on
the blue right now I'm not sure it it
like I said but they're not really good
quality and like I said it's not all
gore like some of the gore is extended
especially like the one scene where
they're watching the video of like the
last of the event horizon crew and like
what happened to them and it was just
like this this horrible like orgy of
like sex of blood and gore and
everything like like I said it's very
Clive Barker so I think that was
extended because the way it is now it's
like I feel like this movie and maybe um
I guess I'm not the person to judge
because I've been watching gory movies
like my whole entire life so I feel like
this
we kind of got a reputation for being
really really gory um and to me it
doesn't seem all that gory yeah you were
gonna say you said really reputation for
being gory and I said bland because at
the time that I saw it I remembered is
it being like yeah whatever because we
took this [ __ ] for granted by the time
97 rolled wrong well I mean to me it
seemed like I mean Hellraiser
to me seemed gory er and that had come
out like 10 years previously yeah so I
mean Candyman was gory or and that had
come out five years the the thing about
it is like there's there's a lot of gore
but it's very quick cut you know what I
mean so it's not like you can sit there
and focus on you know somebody getting
their eyes gouged out or anything like
that they don't really they just kind of
show the aftermath of things and the
effects are really good like I specially
like the dude that gets like eviscerated
like and hung up and all his guts are
down on the table like Silence of the
Lambs style like what Hannibal Lecter
did to that guy in his [ __ ] prison
cell or as a you know in his cell or
whatever lucky hung him up um I do like
that but like I said I don't feel like
they linger on it long enough to to say
that it's gory I think that when I was
readings like some people's comments
about it I think what made people think
maybe that it was gory or than it was is
that they thought it was just like a
standard sci-fi movie so they weren't
expecting it to be Hellraiser level gory
you know I mean so I guess it was more
like a surprise thing than it oh my god
it's so gory thing yeah I you know when
I saw it I was just like you know I
guess in our generation there's a
certain a certain amount of like of
diminishing returns you know had I saw
this at maybe 10 maybe it would have
made a big impression on me yeah yeah I
mean but I you know I saw this you know
after I was out of the army already I
must have been betting on 26 something
like that yeah 27 and it just went right
through me I was like yeah whatever yeah
it didn't care it didn't make much of an
impression the first time I saw it I
liked it the second time that I watched
it more it has good sense
yeah the production design is you
it's I don't find it to be a very
driving story I don't really find it to
have much of a flavor it's very bland to
me it didn't really have much of a
gestalt to it I thought black hole well
I thought was a lot better this you know
has a better tone yeah kind of weird you
know I mean dark you do it no not a lot
happens in the black hole yeah you know
what kind of bothers me about this one
it's like I really like all the actors
in it um sam neill is good in it like
Laurence Fishburne is in it as the
captain he's great uh you know I really
like the guy that was in it that was in
Dog Soldiers I cameras right now but um
I love that guy yeah same same guy from
same bad guy from soul soldier that guys
in it - yeah so it's like all the acting
performances are good and stuff like
that I do feel like this is a movie that
would probably benefit from having the
footage that was cut out put back in it
probably would um you know and it's sad
because tub you know Paul WS Anderson
said that's probably never gonna happen
because I don't know where that footage
went - it's like all I have is like the
shitty thing and obviously we can't put
that back in the movie I found it to be
bland if it had the stuff that was cut
out put back into it probably made a bit
yeah because to me it seems like it's a
little bit um it comes off as a little
disjointed and it comes off as being a
ripoff it's in a little bit yeah and I
couldn't tell you what a ripoff of what
I don't know well I guess it doesn't
look original
a lot of people have said I mean it
obviously pays homage to okay and we'll
put it that way
it obviously pays homage to a lot of
different movies if aliens Solaris like
I said Solaris is almost the same exact
story and I think Mariah and maybe or
something on yeah or something like that
it just seems like a ripoff of
everything all happening at once but it
doesn't really seem like it doesn't
really and it doesn't seem to have its
own character to me but maybe it would
have if it had the other stuff that was
yeah and like I said it's kind of a
shame I wish I could see it the way it
was kind of originally intended to be
seen because I really like the premise I
mean I like the premise of Clive Barker
in space I know that one of the later
helmet Hellraiser movies they actually
didn't get a [ __ ] space I think I
don't think I saw it
like this very much seemed to me like
that which is an intriguing concept I
think it needed a classical score and it
had to have another classical horror
score to it to give the tone that they
wanted and a lot of stuff a lot of the
sets had to be a lot darker as dark as
alien one yeah an alien to the stuff is
too well lit and everything's very
metallic blue yeah that's just and it
just didn't didn't totally strike me
especially you know like I said on par
with the black hole yeah the black holes
to me has an eerie feeling to it than
this even though this one was gory
compared to the black yeah and it and
and the black hole had a more had a
simpler more driving story behind it
yeah this one actually was I think was a
little too fragmented and too
complicated and too many characters I
think and too many characters that just
you don't really seem to really give a
[ __ ] about well they like I said I
that's why I think it would have
benefited from a longer runtime because
I feel like because some of the scenes
that were cut out were more like
character development type of scenes
because you know the the character
development scenes that are in there are
good I just feel like there aren't
enough of them or the editing of it was
strange so it's like it seemed to me
that I couldn't really you know get a
handle on anybody enough like I like I
said I liked the gore but they needed
more of it
I liked the premise I really really
liked the cinematography the production
design like the inside of the event
horizon looks really really cool like I
said that gravity driving like the the
wall around it that cut that [ __ ]
crazy like funhouse type of thing they
go into in the beginning yeah so it's
like I feel like that needed more of
that and I'm gonna say that I guess
because a lot of movies that came out in
the 90s um
I'm not a fan of the nineties as a
decade in general yeah I was hit miss
man I like the matrix there's a lot of
givers yeah but and actually it's funny
that you mentioned the matrix because
that was one of the things I you know
what I think it is and this um I kind of
said this to you while we were watching
this I feel like in the 90s I mean
because you know I had grown up and to a
large extent you had grown up during the
80
like kind of in the goth industrial
scene like into that kind of music and
you know into that kind of look so it
seemed like in the 90s when everybody
discovered it and figured now every
mainstream movie has to have like gothy
looking characters this hard-driving
like industrial music and stuff like
that to me since I had already been into
that stuff it seemed very try hard and
it seemed like a commodification yeah
they never really could get it right and
they never could yeah exactly and it
always seemed like craft good movie but
they never really quite got the goth
feel yeah although firoozeh firoozeh
what yeah she might we actually might do
that one yeah about the music yeah they
just it there's just something about it
that you can tell that the people that
made them or just kind of like jumping
on a bandwagon is it's like suddenly oh
you know goth the goth look and
industrial music is cool
so we have to be cool so we have to put
this in our movie and they didn't really
know anything about it I think and I
think in a lot of ways that kind of like
pissed me off about it is and it's the
reason why I like the matrix but with
the first time I saw it I was kind of
like whatever here we go you know what I
mean
yeah those directors though did we're
into that though they were yeah it's
just it seemed to me that trying to take
something that had been like underground
for so long and then suddenly everybody
wants a piece of it it seems like they
kind of cleaned it up to make it
mainstream they did yeah and it didn't
quite didn't quite pay pay respects to
where the original source was yeah and I
think that kind of annoyed me and I
think that that contributed to my not
necessarily dislike because I did like a
lot of movies that came out in the 90s
um you know for reference I graduated
from high school in 1990 so this was
kind of like my college years or the 90s
and I just even they like the music
after like 1994 I kind of like was not
into anymore just it cuz it seemed like
a lot of the music that I liked it's
like you know it kind of went mainstream
it's like everyone kind of I know it's
dumb to say like you've sold out and
stuff like that but a lot of it just got
not as good everything seems like it was
just getting bland or and blander you
know maybe that's just my perception you
talking about look just give
back on track I want to talk about damn
horror movies in space there's another
one that came out after this I think did
a better job I think was called Pandora
this one is kind of similar to that -
yeah yeah and Dora I liked that movie I
liked a lot better than this one yeah
and and it did have me go and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna spoil Pandorum get
that one I can't even remember what year
that came when did that come out 2010 so
yeah it was 2004 2000 something that one
that one there was like wow you can't
make it me interested yeah and then and
then there's a bunch of flips you like
you know twists to it yeah you like no
[ __ ]
yeah that's a good one yeah yeah I like
that one I think we just saw that I just
I can't remember which one that one and
if you want gothic horror and space you
go for the black hold it Walt Disney's
the black hole and I don't think you can
get it on blu-ray maybe again yeah I
think I tried to find it on blu-ray I
have to go look and see if mines mines
yeah that definitely seems more like an
old-school gothic Horus yeah basically
that's damn Dracula slash Frankenstein
yeah that's cool yeah yeah and it has an
eerie kind of high-class feel to it it
looks is it it's held up we saw it
recently yeah and it there are some
parts where you see some wires yeah but
I didn't notice them too much in the
blu-ray I think they might have I didn't
notice digitally put taking them out
yeah because people complain that
there's a couple scenes where you could
see you see a robot hanging on a wire
it's not really as bad as it used to be
if you see I think I did I think it is
on blu-ray that I got at all yeah I can
I don't never seen any wires yeah I
don't remember either but you know it
was it's an older movie but it looks
like a very expensive important movie
because it was it we had didn't his
attempt to try to dethrone Star Wars I
thought didn't work but it will they
look great I saw it I saw it in a damn
big old [ __ ] mall on right after its
opening in California as a kid my dad
took me to it and they had a gigantic
model of that damn ship the ghost ship
what was it called the oh yeah
the his huge head was lit up on the
inside of it and everything
about 50 60 feet long size of a [ __ ]
boat hanging from the ceiling was
awesome yeah yeah I never forget it and
they were selling models of those damn
Vincent and Bob the damn flying robots
there's a ripoff r2d2 yeah man I wish
they were good though yeah I like that I
like to move you hi Nancy
yeah it's just a fun movie the thing
about it though is that I mean this
movie I will say that for a Clive Barker
in space movie I liked it better than
some of the climb marker adaptations not
Hellraiser obviously or Candyman but I
did like it better than what was that
one with the well raw head Rex that was
terrible yeah good when you were like 16
or 17 and you were just [ __ ] pissed
drunk with your friends well that's kind
of true of any movie that one and the
one with [ __ ] man the one with the
cemetery midian what the [ __ ] is the
name of that movie I can't remember
right now neither one with the monitors
yeah I just totally blanked on yeah the
way I lived underneath the ground yeah
yeah yeah night breeze there you go sir
I like this better than Nightbreed or
like the like better than the movie
adaptation Clive Barker movies are kind
of like hit and miss Madhu's some people
have told me Midnight Meat Train was
good but I still haven't seen it
my breed was mostly good but it was
missing so many elements that you needed
for it I feel like that was another
movie that had your [ __ ] cut out of it
that shouldn't have been I mean
sometimes I think editing is I mean
obviously editing is a good thing most
of the time but sometimes they edit too
much out of things and it makes and I
think that was the problem with event
horizon I just think that I'm not saying
it needed to be the full two hours in
ten minutes I'm just saying that
probably there was some stuff in there
that should have been left in there and
maybe rearranged a little bit to make it
like a little bit more I like I really
like the movie like I like the look of
it and stuff like that but it wasn't one
even though I saw it at the time it
wasn't one that made a huge impression
at the time and like I said that might
have been because of my ambivalence
about 90s movies in general and you know
another thing about the 90s too is that
I love scream as much as that you know
I you know I love that as much as the
next person but I do feel like that was
kind of responsible for oh you know now
let's do all these like stupid slashers
with all these beautiful you know
college-age TV stars like getting cut up
by people with fisherman's hooks and
stuff like that right I know what you
did last summer so so what my my final
verdict on event horizon was is that it
it it was a it was a good movie that had
been neutered yeah didn't quite have the
tone that I looked for i but other
people might like it that's just what I
was saying yeah like I said I I feel
like it needed to be recut and put some
of the stuff back in needed more gore
there was a lot of gore in it but needed
more I feel like it it could have they
could have gone more in that direction
if they were gonna go full on the ship
is possessed and it actually went to
hell and then came back also I think
some of the character motivation could
have been a bit clearer for the same
nails character cuz I don't know like I
said I couldn't really tell if he had
made the ship specifically because he
thought that was gonna happen because he
did kind of turn into a bad guy at the
end but then sort of not because it's
like he was kind of a bad guy but then
you know when that one crew member died
he like looked like he was bummed out
about it even though I thought he would
been possessed by the ship at that point
so I feel like it could have just kind
of been re-edited maybe and rude the
crew is supposed to be kind almost kind
of like a Star Trek level crew but the
problem is you can't you can't get
people to invest in characters just in
one movie the same way you could would
say like Star Trek which it was an
entire series yeah so it had to be
something more along the lines of damn
alien one if they needed to do establish
and if you actually look at the dialogue
at alien one not much as said it's just
a bunch of damn bad or it's very
superficial but it's very effective
they're not what they had here there was
effective in getting you invested in a
character writing down you know writing
characters is hard it's particularly
hard like you said if you don't have a
whole series or a whole novel writing
like that to get yourself like into this
person's head you have to convey a lot
with not very much yeah and a lot of
movies fault
on that I mean you like that in Alien
one the two the two engineers the two
engineers yeah you know that just you
don't know anything about them but yeah
I feel like you've known him your whole
life yeah cuz you just watch them joke
around
yeah and interact and just laugh at [ __ ]
because you know what kind of person
that is yeah did it because everything
that's left in the sand you know
what does exist none of that's addressed
those are very superficial characters
but in a weird way you know exactly what
kind of person that yeah and that is the
Ness now that you get with this that is
a testament to not only the writing but
also the actors you know I think it's
like a good and like I said all the
actors in this are good I just think
that they cut too much out of it yeah so
that they didn't really give you a
chance to get to know them you can't
talk you can't have a character talk his
way into characterization you have to
have an actor that acts that's it be in
that [ __ ] because everything you know
you know a lot of character is not what
people say it's like it's how they you
know carry themselves it's like their
facial expressions the way your body
moves how they react to what it's
somebody else right another character
said right so it's probably only like
maybe 20% what they say maybe not even
that much [ __ ] like I feel like a lot of
it's unspoken when dowsed tells him is
his name Parker
I can't I think it might be Parker went
Taos tells him um I don't want any
heroics out of you and he goes he looks
around you go you could say he's like
[ __ ] that one do it I want I'm gonna
[ __ ] do it I wanna kill that thing
that's that's because you know that
because you can tell from his body his
body line you can tell from his body he
knew exactly I think his name was Parker
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think his knee was
yeah cuz I remember Sigourney Weaver
yelling at him yeah yeah yeah you knew
exactly who Parker was you didn't he
didn't have very many lives or not any
solid lines it was just a bunch of
comments and reactions and [ __ ] that you
know exactly who that was I feel like an
event horizon they tried to have that
like with that one character were but in
a way it kind of didn't work because
tonally it seemed very strange I feel
like he was a little bit over the top
with like [ __ ] Bishop and like you know
when he was like because he got like
outside the ship and then you know
that's just blast himself back which was
funny but I feel like it was a little
too funny for the tone of the movie yeah
you know what I mean well that's a very
fine line to walk they were working fast
I guess yeah and like I said it's kind
of a shame because I really loved the
concept I'm not a huge fan of sci-fi
horror but you know there's some that I
like but um you know so it's gonna have
to be like really good to make a huge
impression on me I could
tell these actors were kind of just
they're just getting paid they probably
even know the whole story of the the
script of the movie yeah you could the
people that worked on alien 1 they knew
they were doing something very special
yeah and they were bringing their own
special magic to the table just just
like with just like with the for the
thing yeah you know carpenters the
version of Yang every dude on that [ __ ]
all every dude in that movie knew they
were on something special and they just
brought it yeah it brought it to the
table and boy the disappointment when et
[ __ ] blew them out of the water that
still bums me out yeah it still makes me
that was that's what I could tell that's
that's what that's what [ __ ] carpenter
up it didn't I feel like he really
didn't cover from that effort piece and
they just went like yeah [ __ ] you but
can you like imagine the Viggen well
yeah you know yeah he'd already made
Halloween and he got like a lot of
accolades for that and stuff but it's
just like when he made like the movie
that he'd been wanting to make yeah and
then like he's like and here it is and
everyone's like hey yeah that's nice
it's not thing still stands to this day
that's what I mean it's still good every
day they're remaking that thing again
that's what I heard yeah okay knock it
off I just I was on a radio you know
it's gonna be CG at well of course I was
on a radio show a day or two ago like in
the UK and they were asking me about
horror movies and they said how did I
feel about like all the remakes and
stuff I said look I'm not I'm not averse
to the very concept of remakes but I do
wish that if someone was gonna remake a
movie they would remake a movie that was
a good idea that was poorly executed the
first time it's like don't take a movie
like John it's like a masterpiece and
just be like okay unless you do
something like Suspiria where you did
something in the same spirit but you did
something totally different and your own
with it that's that that's gonna piss
off thing fans but I'm just saying I I
don't think that that's going to be the
case when they remake the thing I just
feel like that's not gonna be they're
trying to remake Escape from New York
Lee Escape from New York alone that's
what I mean does the brussels alone okay
yeah the press'll aha
thank you all right yeah so anyway event
horizon is on Netflix right now watch it
again if you haven't watched a long time
like I said I liked it better than the
second time it made more of an
impression but I still wish that that it
had been allowed to like just be what it
was to start with instead of like all
the studio meddling and getting caught
up and stuff like that because it might
have been like a way better movie like I
said cuz I really liked the idea alright
so we will see you next time bye